you're now at 30 29 or 31 years old you
went to 36 well male you know peak
market value is 36 to 37 years old
female market value based on your
rationale is 20 to 23 to 20 24 continue
what happens after that well not
necessarily my rationale this is this is
backed up by research and data there's a
great book called data collision and it
was written by the guy who was the
founder i believe of okcupid and um
today in the internet you know age we
now have data that we never had in the
history of humanity right now especially
i don't know if you guys
i i brought this up when i was on you
are here with elijah shaffer um if you
go and you look at the pornhub um blog
site not the pornhub site but all i did
was watch the blog site yeah just read
the book
uh they just put they just produced the
uh the stats for 2021 um of basically
what were the search you know terms what
were the most misspelled search terms
yeah and and by state like who who looks
for what and we have such accurate data
um that tells you like the peak market
values
we have never have i can actually see
that well i can actually see data so
anyways and i don't mean so much on on
on pornhub thing but like in a in a data
collision that's where i get that uh
that's why i might the basis of the idea
that men find you know find that age of
women the most attractive because it's
from their data sets
for women it's uh if the woman is like
say 25 she's looking for a guy that
guy's more attractive is about 27 maybe
28 and then it staggers up at the older
that woman gets the older the men get so
it's sort of this you know staggering
for men it's only 22 23 20 across the
board from all the way from like 15 year
old guys in in high school all the way
up to 95 year old guys in you know
assisted living so um that's
everything i'm getting out here is not
opinion pieces all of this is backed up
by hard hard data that anybody can find
by the way you we have google right now
we can i quote data sets from
evolutionary psychologists
anthropologists
neuro you know psychologists
sociologists there's all kinds of data
sets that we've never had before so it's
not just me sort of pulling this out of
my ass it is based on research that has
you know been going on really in some
cases since like the 70s but all the way
up to where we are right now so when we
get to sort of what i call the epiphany
phase 29 to 31 years old that's when
women decide that that's you know i'm
going to have to check out of the sexual
marketplace i got to find a guy to go
forward from here and that's when women
will express the most frustration with
men they will say where are the nice
guys where are the guys that that how
come these guys don't have their [ __ ]
together how come they uh they haven't
gone to college how come i can't find
the guy that i want to go forward into
life with right now and that's a whole
nother topic to get into when we talk
about the crisis of masculinity but when
they get to that point at 29 to 30 you
know three years old somewhere around
there
that is when the that's when that sort
of angst comes in if you look at the
another data set if you look at the the
average age of first marriage it occurs
right around 29.8 i think or almost
about 30 for men and about 28 to 29
years old for women today and that is in
the united
year states that is exactly where i
pegged it on that on that chart exactly
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]